sometimes your numbers may hit and
sometimes your numbers may not it at the
end of the day you just gotta tell
yourself that you tried and even if you
are on Broadway or you end up being on a
sitcom or in a movie
oh yeah yeah we keep this one yeah that
one went out yeah it just gets upset
I think moment is just hungry it throws
its Tantrums one to the body in the
night time it gets real worse though we
should do that one day we just like come
in the night time and you guys just we
just camp out we'll have like like like
s'mores and something that we just sit
down it would just i'm just show you how
this black ghost just gets out of hand
do right now like that's how it's just
like okay whatever you say mama ghost
like it's just one of those men and just
it's getting late so that i think that's
what it is it's just like I'm just
disrupting them maybe it's like I was
like it's like living with a roommate
that's how bad this ghost is just they
need this space mate you know so you
know that's one of those things I think
so I was thinking about that but then
after that I realized that Shawn is
coming out with a new movie I don't know
if you've heard about it Shawn one of
the Wayans brothers they're doing and
now this thing so I'm like that's a
great concept that's a great idea
because those guys are always good at
doing parodies of those movies and I was
like it's about time they end up doing
something like that so we'll see how
that turns out but yeah that would be
historical I mean it's gonna be it's
gonna be a funny movie so you guys
definitely check that out she'll be
coming I think either January or
February so yeah what does the ghost do
at night just like it would just end up
coming to bed with you sometimes you
just like holy [ __ ] yeah oh my god yeah
but like I said the ranch cheap dough
it's 950 so I just got
I can't I can't you know you did get for
you electricity even free you get all
this stuff so it's like you can't you
know you can't you can't knock that you
know yeah we gotta do a video where you
guys just come in and we'll just do it
like at nighttime and I'll show you that
I'm not trippin like you because I think
have you brought a girl and then the
girl is experience this ghost no I
haven't you know what I don't think he
did isn't it doesn't really flip out a
limb here by myself that's weird isn't
it I that would be perfect that would be
our next video we get like a little
darkness we're getting like like like
yeah but it is crazy though I I don't
think I really ever explore like the
person being here when when somebody's
here actually cuz it's just kind of
crazy but that's just what I'm like here
are my school maybe I'm sure me because
I had no sleep well then how do you find
humor in the fact that there could be a
go I just laugh about it because I just
keep like don't get mad the rest cheap
and like I said you know live with a 90
year old woman you know all these
different things that's been going on
live when the person who was a blind man
like all these things that I've
encounters just like you know it can't
be that bad you know and then living
with people from Craigslist oh my god
it's not it's not us I can't be that bad
but yeah it's what join me
David War for the next episode of can I
go viral well I was soon attempt to make
a viral YouTube video